reporters sans frontières inquiet de la
situation des journalistes en tunisie au
lendemain des violentes répressions
subie par de nombreux professionnels
tunisiens et étrangers en marge des
célébrations du 11e anniversaire de la
révolution ong tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé dans un rapport sur la
dégradation de la liberté de la presse
dans le pays
c'est un rapport d'une trentaine de
pages intitulé l'heure de vérité et
publié quelques jours après la violente
répression observée lors des
manifestations du 14 janvier dernier à
tunis à l'occasion du 11e anniversaire
de la révolution rsf pointe du doigt le
danger qui pèse sur les acquis
démocratiques de 2011 et les violations
de la liberté de la presse de plus en
plus flagrante ces dernières années
notamment depuis le 25 juillet 2021 date
du coup de force du président kaïs sayed
dans son rapport reporters sans
frontières revient également sur les
relations ambiguës entre les médias à la
sphère politique et le monde des
affaires est réel obstacle à la mise en
oeuvre des réformes nécessaires pour
garantir l'indépendance des journalistes
l'augmentation des exactions commises à
l'encontre de ces derniers elle n'a fait
que confirmer les inquiétudes de la
société civile quant au réel engagement
du président sayed dans ce domaine
écoutez il ya une recrudescence des
attaques et de la et des entraves au
travail journalistique depuis le 25
juillet devant un mutisme total de
carthage et du présent isight on a aussi
parlé des liens
entre
les médias certains médias en tunisie et
les hommes d'affaires véreux et leur
l'alignement de certains
l'alignement total de certains médias
sur sur des
partis politiques ou des candidats à la
présidentielle en 2019 notamment et
surtout
l'échec de les réformes du secteur
médiatique tunisien qui sans cela et
c'est la responsabilité
bien sûr des partis politiques et des
gouvernements tunisiens qui n'ont pas
agi pour
mettre en oeuvre les garanties que
contient la constitution tunisienne en
matière de liberté de la presse et de la
formation de l'avis de certains
observateurs ces intimidations
découlerait même d'une volonté direct du
palais de carthage qui malgré les
nombreuses réunions entre le ministère
de l'intérieur et le syndicat national
des journalistes tunisiens elle n'a pris
aucune mesure pour protéger et faciliter
le travail des journalistes écouter
la situation est très mauvaise en
tunisie en ce qui concerne la liberté de
la presse et la liberté d'expression en
général mais aussi en ce qui concerne la
sécurité physique des journalistes et
leur accès à l'information de nombreux
indices montrent que la liberté de la
presse se détériore aujourd'hui
notamment au vu des récentes attaques
contre des journalistes sur l'avenue
habib bourguiba plus d'une vingtaine de
journalistes hommes et femmes ont été
victimes d'agressions diverses
agressions dont des violences physiques
des arrestations musclées sans parler de
la destruction de leur matériel de
telles attaques de la police sont
devenus répétitives malgré nos réunions
répéter avec le ministère de l'intérieur
tout cela nous laisse à penser que ces
attaques contre les journalistes sont
une politique systématique
alors qu'elle incarnait le symbole du
progrès en termes de liberté
d'expression dans le monde arabe depuis
le départ de ben ali la tunisie occupe
aujourd'hui la 73e place dans le
classement mondial de la liberté de la
presse au titre de 2021 selon le rapport
de rsf